monolith softs Xenoblade Chronicles X is
basically the same as its predecessor
Xenoblade Chronicles except it's bigger
unbelievably bigger it's out this month
in Japan but North America isn't getting
it until later this year X is open world
is a welcomed experience for those of us
who are tired of the rigid hallway
formulas favored by many RPGs in the
past decade
you can walk literally anywhere within
the game's five continents on foot and
you can climb on pretty much anything
there are large structures made out of
rock and stone and with the right angle
jumps you can get all the way up to the
top there's never a dull moment in X
because you'll find that the areas
you're in are littered with crafting
materials and roaming monsters something
I love about Xenoblade Chronicles X is
its navigation the Wii U gamepad
displays a world map of sorts with a
couple of kind of strange tweaks rather
than your typical geographical layout
the map is a bunch of diamonds with
icons in them showing what landmarks are
in that area some of these icons
indicate checkpoints which are unlocked
by discovering new areas and then
setting down a beacon if you're killed
in battle any time after unlocking this
checkpoint
you'll be sent back to it until you find
a new one the most helpful tool is the
navigation ball it's a camera that you
can shoot straight into the air for a
bird's-eye view of everything you get
this very large swath of land and you
get to take in your surroundings you can
see monsters around corners and faraway
landmarks it's actually really beautiful
you get a very nice view of the world
that you're running around in combat is
basically the same as the last game the
arts are back which are special physical
and magical attacks but now encina Blade
Chronicles X you can wield a gun and a
weapon and there are special arts for
each speaking of combat enemy levels
don't scale to yours the monsters you
encounter will always be the same level
you can usually go after enemies two or
three levels above yours but not much
more any higher than that and you're
just asking for it on the surface level
Xenoblade Chronicles X is just more of
Xenoblade Chronicles same combat layout
in tone
but X builds on these ideas making them
larger and more complex based on what
we've seen it's a welcome addition to
our PG fans libraries and the Wii U
library as well
[Music]